[Musique]
Jonathan Trudeau à Québec Émilie Nicolas
Michel David Chantal Hébert bonsoir
bonsoir
bonsoir quand même c'est quelle journée
c'est rare qu'on assiste à
il y a eu la TPS on a parlé hier au
fédéral chez la COP c'est tout ça c'est
rare qu'on assiste un recul aussi clair
d'une aussi grosse promesse disons là
Jonathan Trudeau je vais vous donner la
parole mais avant je pense que ça vaut
la peine qu'on réécoute comment Bernard
drinville s'est exprimé là-dessus vous
allez voir très émotif en début de
journée on écoute
je vous le dis
d'emblée c'est un sujet très émotif
je m'étais parlé
[Musique]
je veux d'abord
présenter mes excuses
aux gens de Lévis
et aux gens de châtains
j'ai pris un engagement et je ne suis
pas en mesure de le livrer engagement
que j'ai pris était sincère
le trafic que j'observais les dépenser
il était réel je sais qu'il y en a qui
se sentent trahis et je comprends qu'il
se sent très
ça résume assez bien l'état d'esprit du
caucus de la CAQ de la région choisir à
palache Québec Jonathan Trudeau dure
journée pour Bernardin
c'est extrait là il est très très
important parce qu'on voit premièrement
un député qui était affecté donc vous
êtes bien Patrice ça illustre les
impacts que ça sur les 16 élus kakises
de la région de capitale de la capitaine
nationale et de la chaudière à palache
mais l'autre élément c'est qu'à mon sens
ça vient en tout cas en partie répondre
à une question que bien des gens se
posent est-ce que c'était du théâtre
qu'on nous servait depuis quelques mois
est-ce que ça faisait longtemps par
exemple que la CAQ savait que ce
projet-là ne se réaliserait pas
clairement un des candidats vedettes de
la dernière élection un ministre senior
très influent qui défendait le projet
troisième lien à leur garder aller à
moins qu'on pense qu'il est un excellent
acteur il l'a appris dernièrement
Bernard drinville jusqu'à tout récemment
dans les derniers jours même au cours du
dernier week-end dans des conversations
privées vanter l'importance du troisième
lien disait qu'on devait agir rapidement
etc donc clairement au moins en tout cas
dans le caucus et auprès des ministres
importants il y a bien des gens qui ne
l'avaient pas vu venir en tout cas ça
c'est vraiment la différents clés au
centre de tout ça parce que si il
s'avérait que dans les officines en haut
au bureau du premier ministre pendant la
campagne électorale il le savait déjà
que ce que d'autres disaient à haute
voix les experts que ça tenait pas la
route et qui continuait comme vous dites
Jonathan a joué du théâtre ça serait
toute une autre histoire driner en tout
cas lui dit moi j'ai cru quand j'en
parlais en septembre avec le premier
c'est à côté de moi puis là chez moi
avec les GS dit-il il y croyait Michel
David c'est quand même une question
centrale au cœur du tout ça sur le
cynisme est-ce que ils ont cru
réellement qu'ils allaient faire ce
troisième lien bon d'abord pour Monsieur
Drainville nous dit quand je parlais de
la chalandage puis des gens bloqués
infernal il savait très bien
qu'il y avait des travaux sur le pont
Pierre Laporte et que ça ça causait des
embouteillages il pouvait pas penser
qu'une fois les travaux terminés ça
continuerait de la même façon alors là
ça c'est un morceau que j'ai de la
difficulté pour le reste écoutez
l'atelier travail la pandémie
printemps dernier on avait vu tout le
monde partout au Québec que la
vie à la changer dans toutes les
entreprises y compris au gouvernement
ont commencé déjà à s'adapter au
télétravail on savait que les employés
retourneraient pas pour la pour une
grande partie dans leurs anciens lieux
de travail je suis pas capable
d'imaginer qu'au gouvernement on n'avait
pas pensé que ça pourrait arriver alors
oui moi je suis d'avis que on a on a pas
dit la vérité aux gens de n'arrive Sud
au cours de la campagne électorale vous
dites qu'on a prolongé ce mirage
absolument ok Chantal
ouais je suis assez d'accord avec ça et
là je mets pas Bernard drinville en
cause pour avoir couvert comme vous chez
le COPS ministre et candidates vedette
du Parti libéral qui avait mis son siège
en jeu sur la promesse de la TPS de
Jean-Chrétien et qui d'ailleurs
s'est présenté dans une élection
complémentaire à cause du revirement de
son parti là-dessus mais clairement
madame kope savait pas été mis au
courant de ce qui se préparer ou de ce
qu'elle laisse passer mais j'ai
l'impression moi qu'on s'est dit c'est
quand même pas une autre planète le
bureau du premier ministre quand tous
les experts disent le contraire on peut
pas se dire c'est sûr que c'est nous qui
avons pas mais il y a eu la montée du
Parti conservateur du Québec dans les
mois qui ont précédé la campagne
électorale d'une part et d'autre part je
pense qu'on s'est dit on pourra toujours
tirer la blog excusez l'expression si on
s'aperçoit que c'est vraiment impossible
après les élections et puis on passera à
d'autres choses parce que c'est un
boulet c'était évident même pendant la
campagne électorale que le troisième
lien ne pouvait que devenir un boulet de
plus en plus pesant pour le gouvernement
de la CAF et que le plus vite on
l'arguerait le moins de dégâts malgré ce
qu'on voit aujourd'hui ça causerait à la
marque de commerce du parti oui parce
que Émilie on a posé la question ont été
tous les journalistes tous les jours
lors de la dernière campagne électorale
au Québec sur vous avez pas les études
comment vous pouvez dire que ça allait
ça va aller de l'avant si vous avez pas
les études puis tout le monde répondait
c'est évident qu'un besoin on va de
l'avant etc comme s'il y avait deux
planètes là Émilie
ouais mais je pense que c'est important
de le rappeler parce que en ce moment ce
qu'on dit c'est que les réalités avec le
télétravail a changé que même si par
exemple les gens sont de retour au
boulot après la pandémie le trafic le
trafic est différent il y a moins le
phénomène de l'art de pointe qu'avant
donc on doit moins construire nos
infrastructures routières en fonction
d'une heure de pointe qui tend ne plus
exister donc il y a ça sauf que à la
base le projet existe depuis beaucoup
plus longtemps que ça il existe depuis
bien avant la pandémie et la raison pour
laquelle il y avait aucun expert qui
était peau c'est à cause du phénomène du
du trafic à induit c'est-à-dire plus tu
fais des autoroutes plus les gens
s'achètent de voiture plus les gens
déménagent loin de leur lieu de travail
et plus il y a de plus plus finalement
après quelques années on vient au même
au même au même nombre de voitures sur
les routes et au même genre de trafic
qu'avant donc ça c'est la raison de base
pour laquelle il y avait pas d'études
qui appuyait le troisième lien et c'est
la question je pense que beaucoup de
journalistes posaient durant la campagne
électorale est-ce que vous avez des
études
de faisabilité et puis là maintenant on
se dit mais c'est à cause du télétravail
que le projet que le projet troisième
lien devient devient caduc mais faut je
pense que c'est important de rappeler
qu'à la base même avant la pandémie
c'est un projet de loi qui est un projet
qui était remis en cause par les experts
à cause de ce phénomène-là d'étalement
urbain il y a eu une étude histoire à
l'envers
la ministre un peu la charrue avant les
bœufs Jonathan vous êtes à Québec là
est-ce qu'il y avait pas quand même
cette impression qui manquait une partie
avant de promettre ça il manquait une
étude non non seulement de faisabilité
il y a eu une commande d'étude de
faisabilité en 2016 par massicott le
gars de la Polytechnique mais lui-même
n'a jamais dit on en a besoin vous en
avez besoin et aucune étude ne
démontrait qu'il y avait ce besoin là
pour investir autant là je crois que
alors je vous écoute je vous redonne la
parole tellement de choses à dire
Patrice tellement de choses à dire parce
que non seulement je suis à Québec mais
je suis un lisez je prends la route à
tous les jours
depuis la pandémie oui est-ce que les
temps d'attente les délais la
frustration des gens sur le trafic était
uniquement dû à des travaux temporaires
sur le pont la porte mais non ça fait 8
ans qu'on en parle mais plus que ça
c'est depuis les années 60 qui est
question de créer un troisième lien
entre entre Québec et les vies
maintenant est-ce que le gouvernement
s'il est pris de la mauvaise façon
absolument il a voulu agir rapidement
François Legault qui dit au début du
mandat en 2018 moi je vais faire ça
rapidement je vais tasser sur le
bureaucratie tout ça bah c'est ça ils
ont annoncé un projet qui dans le fond
était mal ficelé qui était pas assez
appuyé sur sur des études parce que il y
a un élément que je trouve frappant
autant je pense que la décision elle
était pas prise à l'avance et là-dessus
en passant c'est des gens qui pensent
qu'il y a une stratégie électorale
nationale qui a été basée sur 16 du côté
alors qu'il savait qu'il prendrait de la
chaleur dans 109 autres compter au
Québec sur le dossier du troisième lit
qui est un dossier national je pense que
la CAC aurait été un peu ça aurait été
un peu risqué vous le croyez Jonathan
vous vous le croyez ce que je pense
qu'il y avait beaucoup de naïveté il y a
des gens qui y croyaient qui je pense se
rendaient compte que ce serait de plus
en plus ardue difficile mais qui disait
on va essayer de trouver une façon de de
le faire maintenant je pense que les
nouvelles données sur les temps de de
passage et tout ça sont devenus un peu
prétexte parce que quand on regarde les
documents rendus public par Geneviève
Guilbaud honnêtement il y a pas de six
grandes variations que ça par exemple on
parle de de trajet de 51 minutes entre
un point de de belles chasses et les
vies 8 minutes d'écart finalement de
moins qu'en 2019 4 minutes le soir 9
minutes d'amélioration on annule pas 10
milliards pour 9000 c'est que en une
année il y a quelque chose qui
fonctionne pas dans la justification
mais en amont de ça c'est comme s'il
manque un gros morceau une étude sur les
besoins c'est comme ici on avait on
avait oublié une grosse étape non moi je
pense qu'il faut se tourner vers les
coups et le réalisme du projet qui avait
été proposé le 15 janvier avec Guilbaud
disait on était rendu à 10 milliards au
lieu de 6.5 et ça c'est 5 6e à une
éventuelle pour un peu de terre donc
est-ce qu'on aurait été à 13 14
milliards de dollars le deuxième outil
du projet qui avait été présenté par
François Bonnardel selon lalal l'analyse
de plusieurs notes n'est pas la route la
sortie des voitures dans le centre de la
ville etc donc je pense que cette
histoire de nouvelles données et devenue
un peu le l'excuse pour finalement
se rendre à l'évidence est-ce possible
je vous soumet une hypothèse pour
discussion là on discute
Émilie Michel Chantal et Jonathan est-ce
possible que la nomination
de Madame Guilbaud quand elle a été
nommée là en arrière de la tête au
bureau du Premier on se disait s'il y a
quelqu'un qui est capable avec ses
talent de communicatrices puis en plus
elle était dirigeante Québec elle est
peut-être capable de nous pour reprendre
l'expression de Chantal de tirer la
plogue puis c'est peut-être celle qui
sera le plus efficace pour le faire
est-ce que déjà est-ce que je suis
machiavélique de penser ça que déjà on
avait ça Michel David en tête
écoutez j'exclus pas cette possibilité
là c'est certain qu'à l'époque
souvenez-vous on parlait aussi de
Bernard drinville au transport et c'est
clair que Bernard Drainville aujourd'hui
ça avait été lui qui avait été chargé de
tirer à plug le spectacle auquel on a
cité aurait été encore plus plus triste
disons
alors je sais pas si c'est vraiment dans
les prévus mais il est clair que quand
tu arrives une affaire comme ça qu'on
l'a vu dans l'histoire de la SAC aussi
madame Guilbaud c'est la meilleure
pompier du gouvernement
paratonnerre Chantal ce matin elle était
seule puis je vais m'en occuper
j'entends et je crois pas qu'elle s'est
faite de tort dans cet exercice là
je le sais pas si on l'a nommé là avec
cette tâche là éventuellement ou
ça m'étonnerait qu'on prévienne
quelqu'un d'avance que le purge jour de
la vie de la CAQ va arriver et XL qui va
se retrouver sous les feux de la rampe
néanmoins
c'est quelqu'un qui est capable de faire
des diagnostics chirurgicaux ce qui est
pas toujours le cas des ministres et qui
qui sait ce que ça veut dire tirer sur
un bandage pour l'enlever d'un seul coup
et qui a la confiance du Premier
ministre parce que ça prenait aussi un
ministre ou une ministre qui amenait des
faits au bureau du premier ministre qui
disait écoutez c'est à ça que ça
ressemble Jonathan parler des 109 autres
sièges c'est 109 autres sièges ça a pas
été une question centrale de troisième
lien mais ça le serait devenu dans
quatre ans au fil des coups au fur et à
mesure que le projet aurait continué à
être mis en doute donc peut-être que
cette fois-ci on ne l'a pas fait pour ça
et siège mais on le certainement fait
aujourd'hui pendant sauver le plus
possible des 109 autres
quand même passé d'un extrême à l'autre
parce que la ministre guilbo a pas aimé
le mot inutile mais elle le dit
elle-même il y a plus d'utilité plus le
besoin n'était plus là dit-elle et trop
coûteux parce que le trop coûteux c'est
l'éléphant dans la pièce Émilie là il
nous ont dit ce matin sa voisinait le 10
milliards
non effectivement on est dans des sommes
d'argent extrêmement élevées dans
laquelle j'ai jamais eu garantie
d'ailleurs justement quelques
investissement du fédéral aussi là c'est
pour ça aussi que c'est un éléphant
blanc c'est intéressant de voir le
vocabulaire qui est mis de l'avance ce
matin en disant on veut un projet de
loisonnier qui soit entré sur les
transports en commun je pense que si on
a ce stade on sait absolument pas quelle
forme ça va prendre ou si ça même ça va
exister mais ça vocabulaire là je pense
que c'est aussi mis de l'avant en se
disant que ce genre de mots qu'il faut
mettre qui qui faut écrire pour avoir la
tension pour avoir la tension de ta voix
pour des projets de mobilité en ce
moment
ceci dit je pense que c'est important de
faire la différence envers le poids
politique sur la Rive-Sud puis la
Rive-Nord les élus qui qui s'en prennent
plein la gueule franchement depuis
depuis quelques depuis mardi soir c'est
Bernard Drainville martine Biron qui
sont sur la réussite il y a pas la même
coupe politique pour une personne qui
est qui est dans le Nord c'est pas la
même réalité le maire de Québec était
pas pour ce projet de loi ce projet
encore une fois lapsus ce projet-là
nécessairement il y a quand même soulagé
même les parties d'opposition à l'Hôtel
de Ville de Québec son soulagés ce matin
les opinions vraiment blessés les gens
très en colère c'est sur la réussite
c'est la mère de Lévis c'est les élus
des petits municipalités autour de Lévis
c'est pas nécessairement Québec comme
tel c'est beaucoup plus nuancé à Québec
et je pense c'est important de nommer
parce qu'on met toute la région dans le
même paquet et franchement les gens
Québec vont rendement sur la Rive-Sud
donc voilà on va écouter Martin Biron
justement on va écouter Martin Biron
puis on le sentait aussi un peu moins
que chez bernardinville mais quand même
on le sentait là elle a une journée
difficile d'ailleurs j'ai parlé au maire
de Lévis puis elle avait l'oreille rouge
encore on écoute
oui ils sont trahit le choc est énorme
on a fait campagne là-dessus c'est sûr
qu'aujourd'hui on est dans une situation
où on fait pas ce qu'on a promis puis
c'est une valeur importante quand on dit
aux gens moi même dans ma famille à moi
tu es Jésus j'ai toujours respecté mes
engagements et apporter une importance
capitale à respecter mes engagements
je vous envoie deux extraits avant de
conclure tous ensemble un peu sur la
morale de l'histoire vous allez entendre
madame Guilbaud et Monsieur Drainville
dire là le nouveau projet qu'on vous
annonce là faut pas se tromper le faut
être préparé on écoute
oui il va avoir un échéancier c'est sûr
aujourd'hui je vais pas m'engager dans
des affaires je vais être obligé de
déduire ou c'est bon là ce que je dis
aujourd'hui c'est que on se concentre
ici tracé choix du mode à définir
échéancier précis plus précis à définir
en conséquence et quand je serai prête
je vais vous revenir avec ces détails là
le tunnel
ça va être ça va être un investissement
de plusieurs milliards de dollars pour
notre région
ça va être un immense chantier
mais là on peut pas se permettre de se
tromper on peut pas se permettre de
passer
là on peut pas se permettre de se
tromper Jonathan le tour de table je
pense avec vous
pas évidemment ça aurait été futile et
hasardeux de donner l'un des détails
précis sur la nouvelle mouture d'un
parce qu'ils veulent pas refaire la même
erreur et de s'avancer avant d'avoir des
données probantes probantes mais aussi
parce qu'il faut que les gens gèrent la
pilule avec tout le respect pour pour
mes collègues montréalais moins tant
Québec est animateur de radio à Québec
évidemment le coût est peut-être plus
dur encaisser en choisir un palache mais
à Québec aussi les gens sont très fâchés
le demandeur député Sylvain Lévesque
Eric car évidemment
entre nous il devrait je pense ce serait
d'aller à la chose la plus sage à faire
mais à ce moment la population elle est
très très fâchée la Bonne Nouvelle si je
peux dire ainsi pour laquelle c'est
qu'ils ont au moins le mérite d'avoir
tiré sur le pansement d'un coup sec
rapidement dans le mandat ce qui va leur
permettre d'essayer de faire avancer
d'autres idées puis je disais un peu
plutôt à la blague aujourd'hui si vous
êtes je sais pas moi promoteur vous avez
un projet de de centre sportif de centre
culturel de le spectacle dans des comtés
Québec choisir Appalache il y a des
bonnes chances que les projets soient
acceptés assez rapidement au cours des
trois prochaines années
Émilie ouais ça laisse des traces là sur
ça laisse des traces dans la population
sur le site ça alimente le signe quand
même oui absolument juste pour revenir
sur ce que je disais les réactions
politiques surtout au niveau municipal à
Québec sont très beaucoup plus nuancés
que les que les c'est ce que je disais
ce que je continue à dire d'ailleurs on
est deux livres sur le panais chaud
c'est intéressant c'est
mais ce que ce que ce que je ce que ce
que je souhaitais dire c'est que si on
veut avoir des projets pour la région
qui sont plus réalistes effectivement
sur le terrain il y a des gens qui sont
blessés mais je pense que ça va être
important de se trouver quelque chose
d'autre pour pour assurer d'ailleurs je
parle à ma famille aujourd'hui puis une
chose qu'on entend beaucoup dans les
régions c'est les inquiétudes pour la
santé du pont de Québec donc avant de
conduire la question de la santé du
premier et ça ça va ça risque peut-être
de capturer les intentions maintenant de
capter les attentions maintenant que le
projet de liens est un peu surface
beaucoup sur pour je vous je vous prête
désolé Chantal Hébert avec seconde
Michel quelques secondes
d'une façon d'une autre
le premier conseil c'est pensez pas à
faire campagne sur ce troisième lien si
existe encore transport en commun aux
prochaines élections provinciales
d'abord parce que ça va ramener les
plaids aujourd'hui puis deuxièmement
parce que personne va les croire Michel
disait il faut pas se tromper la
prochaine fois mais je pense on va dire
que la meilleure façon de pas se tromper
c'est de pas faire de projet alors moi
j'ai un gros doute là sur la suite des
choses on repart à zéro et quel que soit
le scénario il y aura pas de travaux
avant la prochaine élection et après
prochaine élection on comprend que
Monsieur le gouv veut rester encore un
peu mais c'est un gros point
d'interrogation pour l'après 2026 nous
avons un gros journée demain aussi
Jonathan à la radio là parce que c'est
les gens sont pompés puis on peut
comprendre merci beaucoup Jonathan
Millet Michel Chantal à la prochaine
merci au revoir bonne soirée
[Musique]